[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
our attention to an article from one of
our local outlets here in tennessee
called the tennessean in a recent piece
the tennessean extends an invitation to
us that none of us asked for or wanted
headline is
meet nashville's trans queer latinx
neurodivergent theologian
now
you'll notice already that this headline
is nominally six words long and yet
after the second word nashville it takes
a three-word detour into utter gibberish
and doesn't return to reality and words
that exist in the dictionary until the
end with the word theologian everything
in between is abject nonsense this gives
you an idea as to what to expect as we
venture into the text of the article
itself it begins
robin henderson espinoza is the only
nashville-based trans queer latinx
neurodivergent public theologian that
they know
wait
that who knows that they know
sounds like there's a sentence cut off
here or maybe the author of this piece
had a stroke while they were typing but
it turns out that of course the they
refers to robin henderson espinoza who
despite having three names is only one
person but still goes by they anyway and
it continues
i don't know anybody like me henderson
espinoza who uses gender neutral
pronouns said in an interview
yet it was only recently when henderson
espinoza 45 got to know their better
self or rather got to know their self
better
got to know their self better
okay
such as the diagnosis that they are on
the autism spectrum amid this eventful
period in their life henderson espinoza
also made time to write reflections
about their personal experience
and its connection to larger
socio-political events which they turned
into a book henderson espinoza's new
book body becoming a path to our
liberation released on tuesday
somehow i don't feel a threat from that
book to johnny the walrus i don't think
that i have to worry about that making
it into the top 10.
um i must again though point out here
that the the correct
gender-neutral pronoun for an individual
entity
is it
so if you're really neither male nor
female and yet you're a single person
then you are an it
but robin just like every other supposed
gender-neutral person doesn't want to
use it because that sounds dehumanizing
which it is but rejecting the binary of
female and male is by its nature
dehumanizing as you are rejecting the
very human nature which declares that
there are only males and females
these people want to have their
dehumanized cake and eat it too um robin
says that she and i i think this is a
female but i'm taking a bit of a shot in
the dark here um she is unlike anyone
she knows incredibly unique i don't know
anybody like me
now that's obviously the point of all
this the accumulation of meaningless
identity labels is a narcissistic
attempt to present yourself as more
complex more interesting deeper more
profound than the average person
and yet it has precisely the opposite
effect but she's not done claiming
labels the continuous henderson espinoza
an ordained baptist minister who has a
phd in philosophy knew for many years
that they were transgender but didn't
explore what that meant to them until
2017 when they moved to nashville from
california henderson espinoza found a
vanderbilt physician who was overseeing
henderson espinoza's hormone therapy
then in 2018 henderson espinoza learned
that they're on the autism spectrum it
never occurred to me that my brain
worked differently henderson espinoza
wrote in their new book i realized that
my socialization in the church and
academy had been through neuro-normative
people who didn't understand my body or
my mind it had curated such a
disconnection from my body
wait
if you didn't
if you don't identify as either male or
female then what are the hormones
supposed to achieve exactly
meanwhile robin addicted to the
self-satisfied high she got from
accruing the labels trans non-binary
latinx
decided to go back for another hit
adding neurodivergent to the list
has this happened with so many other
things the category of mental illness
has now been fully subsumed
by the lgbt alphabet crew
this is why lgbt activists will so often
list their mental health conditions as
if the conditions themselves are sexual
identities
and like sexual identities
mental illness has been made into
something trendy you know desirable
another way to set yourself apart
the made-up term neuro-normative has the
same scoffing tone and dismissive ring
to it as the made-up term cisgender and
that's the other thing about all of the
obsessive labeling that leftists do to
themselves
while labeling themselves
they also put labels on the rest of us
that we did not choose or agree to or
consent to
cisgender is not a term that any
so-called cisgender person chooses for
themselves it's a label that trans
activists place on us
now god forbid we label them in a way
they don't like
but you know they can label us all they
want
those are the rules they want us to play
by anyway but i refuse
also note in that last segment again
the sheer volume of absolute certifiable
nonsense especially the last sentence
i realized that my socialization in the
church and academy had been through
neuro-normative people who didn't
understand my body or my mind and had
curated such a disconnection from my
body
curated a disconnection from your body
how is a disconnection curated
how can someone else curate your own
disconnect whatever that means
what in the hell are you babbling about
well robin does quite a lot of babbling
it turns out
this is common of leftists generally but
especially those who identify themselves
as pastors and theologians
those two labels as it happens are the
most absurd of all the titles robin
gives to herself as evidenced by this
clip of robin henderson espinzoza
originally posted to twitter by a group
called q christian fellowship which says
in its bio that its mission is to
cultivate radical belonging for lgbtq
plus people and it achieves this
apparently through incoherent prattle
like this listen
the not yet is the imaginal space of
becoming
the not yet is
is in the space of a realized utopia
the not yet is the christian message
that we must embody in critical and
creative ways
to steward a narrative that calls us
into being human with one another again
that is the kind of hope
i want to invite us to embody
that is the kind of queerness
that i hope we can practice
one that reimagines language and
practice and narratives
that can be midwifed and stewarded
through the imaginal
that
is hope to me
that is the kind of power
i think we have as a collective of
believers
of doubters
of christians
as those who are becoming
so this is like the leftist version of
speaking in tongues because no part of
what you just heard qualifies as english
neither does it qualify as christian i
mean it is religious no question but
this is not the christian religion
you're hearing there
um just to quote one section of it she
says
that is the kind of queerness that i
hope we can practice one that reimagines
language and practice and narratives
that can be midwifed and stewarded
through the imaginal
oh okay
now
if you listen to that and you hear all
the big words and think well maybe i'm
just too stupid to understand what she's
saying then you're having exactly the
reaction that people who speak this way
want you to have and you're also wrong
you are not too stupid
your failure to understand gibberish is
not a shortcoming on your part
this is just how smug leftist academics
speak because for one thing they would
rather dazzle you with their faux
intelligence than actually communicate
like normal human beings
they don't want to be understood
they want to be admired
when it comes to leftist ideas in
particular this is especially the case
they hide behind this impenetrable
fortress of scholarly sounding
because along with wanting to impress
you with what it usually turns out to be
a pretty middling intellect they also
want to disguise their true meaning
such as there actually is any true
meaning at all whatever they're trying
to say if they're trying to say anything
they prefer to keep it safe locked
inside a you know a box of gibberish and
buzzwords
the hope is that you'll just nod
confusedly and go along with whatever it
is they want you to do or whatever
direction they want to take you
they want you to scratch your head and
shrug your shoulders and say uh okay
sure let's be uh
stewarded to the imaginal space of
queerness
sounds good
what they don't want you to do is stop
and say wait a second what exactly are
you trying to say
can you speak like somebody who isn't
suffering from a severe conversion
concussion and just put it in plain
english for me
they don't want that because if there is
any meaning underneath all this nonsense
it's something quite horrifying
something that they clearly
don't want you to see
or understand
and that is why finally robin the
neurologist transbinary divergent
theologian
is today canceled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content